et à nouveau nouvel homme le plus riche
du monde oui on va l'homme le plus riche
du monde oui on va dire qu'il est
l'homme le plus riche du monde
c'est elon musk et ouais il est devenu
l'homme temps plus il est un peu beau
gosse objectif là-bas il et il a une
fortune évaluée à 180,5 millions
milliards de milliards de dollars
ça veut dire le mec qui arrive et qui
est devant lui et 488 millions de
dollars un bouffon et le cerveau parce
que les gens les riches mais qui tue à
[ __ ] avec 188 milliards de dollars
tu as acheté une planète non mais sans
rigoler je tais toi t'es tu vas acheter
lui c'est ce qui permet si mal fait la
lune mais je sais il a plein de
schindler a dit j'ai demandé à la lune
il a donc dépassé
jeff bezos jeff bezos c'est le patron
d'amazon et vous savez pourquoi les le
plus riche parce qu'il détient 75% de
ses actions maintenant ont pris tout de
même 700 43% dans l'année la plus grosse
pour brûler progression le mondial 1 2
de tout l'univers
vous êtes la plus mauvaise progrès le 3e
plus riches du monde c'est big dez il a
fait fortune dans les mers il à 132
milliards de dollars c'est l'inventeur
de la carte à puce c'est pas mal c'est
lui qui a monté la garde à vue non pas
du tout français
non il guette si bien les faire voter la
carte à puce et or c'est bien sûr c'est
patrick fiori
on est français c'est bernard arnault
avec 114 milliards de dollars
et il a perdu trois places la séance il
est comme ça il roula les mecs la liste
il entre au spi de ouf